welcome to this video playing Grand
Master sleep acha he's from Argentina
it's also the Argentinian flag Sarah
Sergei i think is it sergey sall g oh
sorry yeah sergio say again yeah is so
so much used to those Russian names okay
we got a Queens gambit declared he's a
specialist of this opening a six don't
see that one too often probably not that
bad ok let's take Bishop g5 a sick is
quite a success quite often useful move
in the Queens gambit huh what that looks
that looks weird it really looks weird
wow wow b5 are you kidding me I just
check my cheek f6 and tick g5 ok let's
take first 95 for the sea doing Quinn da
idiom because of c6 hmm I still don't
believe in that force is 6
even simply III is pretty good a 4b 495
2084 66
hmm yeah I see some interesting
continuations but i'm not sure if they
are enough let's do that it's a bit it's
a bit hmm Jim okay it's it's I wanted to
play a for actually a 4b 495 was my idea
yeah this is not working ah silly silly
a4 before I have to play first I do tech
yeah against this [ __ ] set up I'm
sorry this is just totally bad what
black did here and I'm making a simple
slip up and move all I have to play for
first okay my idea was a 4b for that
half Bishop c4 now that is actually a
very interesting piece sacrifice that
was my idea to try to refute his his
setup but now I don't have anything at
all I mean just nothing yeah okay I'm
going to continue a little bit but this
is this is just ridiculous what I did
here against this this is really this is
just total nonsense iam sorry he can be
a grandmaster whatever this is just
nonsense chess ok so let's let's just
see maybe I can still try to get
something him if you play some some more
strange moves i might still have some
kind of chance in this game but i'm just
a piece down objectively speaking ok so
he is going for night to f8 i'm trying
to get in f4 f5 a possible g6 however is
a good defense iam
maybe yeah I have to avoid the trade SIA
being the piece down at f4 f5 f4 so he
wants to ok maybe
that's no really okay i can try that 46
that doesn't really help them he has
Queen d6
Queen d6 is ok also taking f take C and
then having 26 is quite ok
a stupid ad is wrong just I just wanted
to play the other move I hit rating
plate and I just just totally stupid
okay um yeah they took with the bishop
which is also of course okay I'm just
continuing a little bit out of
frustration they're losing against this
is this kind of opening place is really
frustrating but okay if you confuse your
move order it so it's probably well
deserved
Joe Black has many many possible ways to
win you can also play f6 the whole time
which she does not do not quite sure why
what is he doing there going for Luke's
you won okay maybe I'm can bring the
Queen up
okay and queen h4 is probably good
trying to trade queens of course I
cannot do that being the piece down
Jeff g3 is not the most sophisticated
idea but you never know okay so time
morning I can't let's go g3 Queen age 3
is just good let's shoot for Bishop g2
the Queen doesn't have many squares okay
so what is she doing formed for look I'm
sorry for Bishop t5 maybe probably
Bishop d5 as possible
I think you can still play Bishop g5
okay didn't if I go rook age for now
what does this move there is giving the
Queen on what is he doing is giving the
Queen okay dwell I'm still of course
worse but I'm kind of catching up a
little bit here the deep on the dip the
Damned upon he really had screwed it up
again and no I'm just cannot stop the
deep on them now okay let that you will
manage right just I'll just push the
deep on yeah I'm sorry about not being
very respectful to my opponent but this
is this opening play it's just like this
is really terrible yeah I mean it
besides any tactical tries that I did I
can just play III or something and this
is strategically terrible it's just
terrible it weakens the whole Queen side
and this is this just nonsense but okay
I had an interesting idea but I screwed
it up with my move order I wanted to do
this a 4 B 4 we should have six Queen F
695 I'm showing in this line and the
difference is the following efore c6
Bishop c4 that was my idea takes takes
bishop anywhere and then I wanted to
cancel and I thought okay interesting
I'm not sure if this is good but I
thought this is interesting the ideas i
have d six possible and i get against
rookie one in I mean okay can play
Bishop t6 check and something like this
I thought it's interesting I mean maybe
it's not great or whatever but it was
interesting to try and this is just not
working at all we are because i don't
have the move Bishop c4 I need after
each one
six I need to have Bishop c4 yeah this
is the problem and I have a need this
force moves for Bishop c4 what a city
city way to lose yeah I continue despite
being a clear piece down and German yeah
blundered the Queen Queen away somehow
are they on the edge of the board but
it's still a win like black has too much
material there rook to pieces and those
pawns it's still it's still too much and
this was very easy allowing him to push
the the deep on deep on home very
frustrating against this opening this is
kind of b5 pretty cool yeah well
probably you just should play like III
something something simple and just
review this in in a in a positional way
that's probably the way to do it okay
well thanks for watching